hello I wanted to make a statement on
what I said in my previous livestream
you probably won't believe me when I say
this but whenever I go online and I hear
other players use the same kind of
language that I did I always find it
extremely immature and stupid and I hate
how I now personally fed into that part
of gaming as well it was something that
I said in the heat of the moment I said
the worst word I could possibly think of
and it just sort of slipped out and I'm
not gonna make any excuses to why it did
because there are no excuses for it I'm
disappointed in myself because it seems
like I've learned nothing from all these
past controversies and it's not that I
think I can say or do whatever I want
and get away with it that's not it at
all I'm just an idiot but that doesn't
make what I said or how I said it okay
it was not okay I'm really sorry if I
offended hurt or disappointed anyone
with all of this being in the position I
am I should know better I know I can't
keep messing up like this and I owe it
to my audience and to myself to do
better than this because I know I'm
better than this I really want to
improve myself and better myself not
just for me but for anyone that looks up
to me or anyone that's influenced by me
and that's how I want to move forward
away from this that's all I had to say
thank you for watching bye